[Music]
well we need this in faith in humanity
restored news oh yes submitted by
Natalia dire is wifey's oh that's cute
Oh Tina's praise online after he was
seen filling an empty trick-or-treat
bowl with his own candy wow [ __ ] up a
world do we live in that that is that is
like faith restored in humanity of team
did what TV Philip there was an empty
trick-or-treat boy and he filled it with
his own case oh I have a quick question
is that an act of gratitude or stupidity
I think no its gratitude or its general
generosity yeah it's also the generosity
or is the kid doesn't understand how
trick-or-treating work it might be the
latter it's kind of stupid because all
you got to do is knock on the door and
say hey you ran out of candy so a lot of
times those people leave like are not
home
it's like I was about to do that I went
home for the first time in like years to
like my home home for Halloween and my
parents were at my sister's place so no
one was at their house
she left the big-ass no they know
they're too cheap to do that they just
turn the lights off but there's a
situation where they would put them oh I
guarantee you some [ __ ] got that
whole bowl put it in his back and then
just good so my mom as she always tells
us the story on Halloween so when we
were little she did that once cuz she
was taking us out but I guess before we
left or something she put the bowl out
she saw kids take the bowl and she ran
after them how his goal to them and told
him to put it back because what I would
do instead is I would have a big thing
of just awesome candies but I'm gonna
create a contraption in the front sizes
you only get one or there will be
consequences
what happens is your hand gets chopped
off yeah how do they know how you know
that you didn't have a monkey because
technology at this point will be so
advanced there will be something for
this there will be something over the
counter to like something you get at
Target
there's an app that's a good idea yeah
and then after he gets chopped the blade
is hot so it seals the wound right so
it's not it's not completely you know
Cotuit is it's like yeah yeah I don't
want the bleeding all over my I'll just
statement no infection it could be like
you know the face recognition Chinese
toilet paper thing we're like you have
to go up to the Machine and then they
scan your face and they give you a
certain amount of toilet paper it could
be that for you wait what is it is that
a different news yeah they were stealing
toilet paper in China and they needed
face recognizes crazy you know give them
like a certain amount of do that lookin
out work for me because I like I
wouldn't need a lot that's all my mom
wipes too
she doesn't want it wait hold on hold on
actually wait are you guys a clump err
or you guys folders Oh what's a clump er
some people some people just want it and
then but you can what if there's a girl
and I was freaking out what I felt close
to some people because we have to know
it was there was some like friends that
you don't know but like I was all les
clumps up there [ __ ] toilet paper
there's so much or there's some people
that do on that's my mom you roll it
like around your hand wasteful
she's always clogging up the toilet
every since I'm her oh no we don't want
yes she does that all the time doesn't
make any sense
she's she had like this phobia of like
feeling yeah and she just doesn't want
to touch it straight once you know it's
not a big deal
alright got it I don't know I'll just
say this Charmin ultra that is the best
toilet paper out there you sponsor I'm
not I would totally take their
sponsorship it is the best one i [ __ ]
with it yeah you only need like three
max three sheets max I just shower after
no it's not because of Charmin all right
so this takes place in Chula Vista's oh
this is like
way though so the homeowner came she
took out her kids to go
trick-or-treating around the
neighborhood and so she left out a bowl
for trick-or-treaters outside of her
home and she said that once she got
around the block and she came back the
bowl was already empty and so she was
really she was hoping that the bowl
wasn't emptied by like one kid or by a
Buddha or something so she decided that
he's so pathetic
no I'm pretty sounds like my
neighborhood though and then so she went
to review her her security footage and
she found this video of her and she
found that there was this team that
ended up putting some of his own candy
in the bowl and so she thought it was
really sweet and she posted up on
Facebook on like a neighborhood Facebook
page and then it just went by how much
you want to bet he was the one that
stole it and then he thought yeah guilty
any put somebody but she has no she has
a video she would have seen the people
so is there a video I'm with David
always changed costumes yeah yeah yes
yes he's took it as Joker and he came
back as Batman and then his mom was like
where'd you get all this candy in like
15 minutes [ __ ] and then she made
them come back let's see let's see let's
see it here we go
i discredit this poor good kid yeah see
we came from we're in a world where we
can't even believe in good accent I'm
suggesting here's everything speak news
yeah let's see this let's double so his
friends took all the camels so they
approached they approached the bowl and
it was already empty and so this kid
later on they found out that this kid
was and he said that when he saw the
empty bowl he felt bad for the next
trick-or-treaters after him and so he
decided to put them on his own candy
he's gonna be poor what the cool thing
is that this guy just showed that his
other friends are [ __ ] garbage could
have done it but he did it after always
spreads like Dane we could be famous
right now that's right you're sure we're
talking about it on JK news you could
have been one of the cool kids yeah so
this is Kim the homeowner she's being
interviewed but not huh yeah and so she
was saying like at the time of her
interview she was like I really want to
find this kid like
it was just so sweetly I get really warm
I give him a scholarship
JK scholarship is this an interval takes
us from Jo why hell naw that was gonna
give it away like a t interview picture
it's a screenshot from her okay and then
they found the kids somehow oh because
she's in the middle of thing yeah yeah I
think not too bright so then they found
the kid and there was this kid pebbles
growl wait then they said he's a team
yeah teenies 15 he looks like he's a
solid 30 - yeah he looks like he's like
it the changes a lot I mean if this guy
is 15 and all the trick-or-treaters are
like eight I can see that happening when
he's like oh man I don't need his candy
as much as he's oh yeah he's old enough
to know what have morals
he's also all of us did not trick or
treat anyone yeah I was thinking that he
could afford to not have some of this
candy yeah I'm like he was saying like
he moved to the u.s. from the
Philippines four years ago new home in
like and he wanted he's participating in
American tradition so they don't
trick-or-treating just walking around
like I don't have candy so they're just
gonna yeah maybe they forgot to put some
in there yeah so this went viral cuz
their own was like how sweet of that kid
and what a good guy and that's when Kim
was saying that her kids wanted to give
their own candy to this kid because they
thought it was just so he's on a trip
yeah you know what though his name is
Lawrence and so Kim's kids wanted to
give their own candy to Lawrence and
that's when when Lawrence is being
interviewed the reporter asked him like
oh yeah you know would you take the
candy he was like no I I just I would
have done I did what anyone else would
have done something clearly I know cuz
your friends are garbage did you have
two friends over there that did it yeah
mister JanSport backpack two friends are
two they could be [ __ ] Niners alright
cuz the older you get the price of candy
and the commodity is lower in value when
you're a child like you buy unless your
job four years old the candy is like a
[ __ ] million dollars yeah
it still is
that's why well you could buy as many as
you want when you're 15 you know you
could buy some more it's not that much
he would trick-or-treating last year
that wasn't the daughter says you
apparently the free candies very
important today we went with Isaac oh
yeah that was two years ago yeah yeah
yeah but that's with the kid though
there was a purpose behind it wait when
you went in you when you went
trick-or-treating with the kid you
weren't at the door asking for it either
you're just there all right the kids
back oh my god I did I did pass out
candy though and adults would show up in
costumes and like I thought they're just
there for their kids but they opened the
bags too so I was like oh I want to be
that I want to be the house that gives
out toothpaste into you yeah you should
you know what if there's adults this
should be an adult bowl that you get and
it has like condoms or just like or just
like you know like fiber fish fish oil
I'm gonna give all the kids Jehovah
Witness pass change your life change
your life candy in front of them that is
a that is a nice warm hearted story
though do you guys see that
like one tweet that was going around of
like from like Donald Trump jr. you guys
see that one oh yeah with his dog wait
you guys talk about Paulette no no you
go ahead but like he took a picture of
this girl this little little girl it's
his daughter and he's like now I'm gonna
take half her candy to a kid that stayed
at home and sure what socialism is and
it's like what the [ __ ] well first of
all you just took free candy he's so so
you're already like like you know and
then oh my god there's just so many
things that were wrong with that tweet
it's like like it himself like you know
just basically got a free ride his
entire life too so it's like what are
you yeah how do you know I did my hard
work I think that family is a family of
professional trolls like I think they
know how to do [ __ ] on purpose to make
people start talking about them but then
why is the reaction of people talking
negatively about them than becoming
president
how do they figure that out well I use
like I said I used to think that until
Donald Trump came up and he says I wish
my wife was here and she was then I was
like oh he's just senile he's crazy
Melania which sends you our best wishes
she wishes she was here right now and
his wife goes oh she's a crazy person oh
my god but anyways going back to the
whole Halloween trick-or-treating thing
did you guys give out I mean candy this
year yeah yeah well our place that I
live at has a gate code so they have to
know that number to come in so [ __ ] no
so right so just everyone in our
community those coils I thought was hard
to get you because I got to meet other
people in the community that live on
like the other side and stuff which I
never really do see David lives on a
castle on a hill he's like don't don't
worry coordinates you could go and visit
his house it would be the time I get a
gun and then I shoot myself first people
because my sister lives in like a little
suburb and yeah there weren't that many
yeah is it a dying holiday I used to
think that they say that every year like
it's less and less but it's so round cuz
that's a kid I remember seeing kids like
everywhere on the streets it looks like
swamp no I remember too that a lot of
homes did like themed haunted houses and
I know what I've discovered now because
every single year we always try to find
where to go for Isaac to go to the
treating and now I realize that the
richer everyone is just like each
neighborhood has their own like specific
street or two streets and like that's
the place where you go you don't go to
the whole I will tell you why because
kids be getting raped
that's why well in our generation was
the poisoning all you need to check that
there was a whole bunch of needles in
candy yeah see that's why if you want
candy I'll buy you candy dumbass but
yeah you think you take your kid I'll be
like say just say trick-or-treat
and then just give me you know go to the
house first yeah I'm gonna give you this
candy just keep it right back you know
what you know what it is though is
because that sense of a small community
is disappearing people don't talk to
their neighbors anymore they don't say
hi they don't do the whole lights we not
we talk to our neighbors you're kicking
a [ __ ] punching bag in front of them
there's that grandma says what's up to
us what's her name what's up grandma
power walking the power walking ground
we don't talk about yeah yeah I thought
is it a lot of work though because if
you become your need to talk to them and
then invite them all it's like God [ __ ]
I don't really don't then fight them
over I think once you have a family
though it's different I think you'll
want to know you'll want to know what's
who's living around in my place I only
have a relationship with the person next
to me and the condo in front of me
that's it what condo living is
completely different than yours I like
to do it a lot although I don't think
his wife likes me too much but the
neighbor
I have relationship with him too cuz I
yelled at him so we have this great
community do you guys remember at what
age your parents let you go
trick-or-treating alone never never
really you never selected it I was like
fourth or fifth grade well your mother
no it was like stranger things where we
would go on a bicycle and and we would
just hit like superheroes in the 80s no
I'm not that old but like uh what we
would do is we so at that age or older
now right so you're older than a lot of
the other kids we would just get trash
bags and we would just [ __ ] bike as
far as we can and then come back door to
door door to door and we would just come
back with a huge freaking loop I never
like candy enough to like Halloween oh
my god
[Music]